So let me tell you what
we're not going to cover.
In exactly the same way we talked about
bag of words for recognition of objects,
where you cre, you, you have some way of
finding interest points in an image, and
then you cluster all those
interest points into code words.
Remember that?
And then you describe each image by
its histogram of the code words, and
then you build a classifier to
recognize these histograms?
Well you can do the same thing in video,
right?
So you can, you can pull out
these little interest points.
This guy is moving, and
his hand is swinging, or over here,
or maybe this car is moving.
And that would build you,
you could extract some features.
But now, remember the volume in video,
your feature points,
your interest points are in space time,
instead of just in space.
And you could pull out little spacetime
patches, sometimes called cuboids, in,
in some of the work, where they're
just these little chunks of spacetime
imagery, and
that builds you your descriptions.
You can then do feature
quantization to learn codewords.
You do this over all your videos.
Then for an incoming activity, you can
look for the interest points, you can
build a histogram of these codewords,
and then you can train a classifier.
And here they talk about using
an SVM with a chii squared kernel.
The reason we're not going to talk
about that, although it's good work and
interesting work is, it's in some sense,
only the three dimensional,
from 2dxy to 3dxyt.
It's just the three dimensional
extension of the previous work done on
bag of words, or
things like bag of words.
Instead, we're going to talk
a little bit today, and then also,
next time, on some representations that
fundamentally are about how things move,
or about time series.